the most important thing is for vladimir
putin not to win this war
we're not talking about negotiations
we're talking here about supporting
ukraine uh making sure that ukraine's
got the ability to defend itself and
britain has been right at the forefront
in making sure that military equipment
reaches ukraine and the ukraine has a
full set of sanctions on russia and
those in charge in russia
to make sure the pressure is brought
economically on russia so that is the
priority making sure that putin doesn't
win this conflict
uh okay thank you minister thank you um
mr hands now let's pick up on um the
plan to send asylum seekers to rwanda
the archbishop of canterbury over the
weekend called the plan ungodly is he
wrong
well look i think what others the
critics of this plan need to do is to
show what their solution would be you
know we have a position now where last
year 28
500 people across the channel illegally
into this country
that compares just 300 in 2018. this is
a growing problem uh we've taken a bold
and innovative measure with this
agreement with rwanda to take action
here and i think the british people are
in support of that
i mean you're not expecting the people
of canterbury to come up with policies
how to deal with migration but it's the
point he's making isn't it that we are
in his words outsourcing responsibility
which doesn't fit with christian values
he's not wrong about that is he we are
outsourcing our responsibilities no
we're not this is an agreement between
two sovereign countries the uk and
rwanda
um where rwanda with its uh very good
track record on taking
uh refugees asylum seekers um the uk uh
it's a it's a solution it's an
innovative solution uh it's not entirely
without precedent other countries have
done similar things in the past and it's
uh the government taking action here as
i say there's 28 500 people last year
moved from one safe country to another
illegally 27 people died it's about
taking the tough action
particularly on the people smugglers and
those who are profiting uh from human
misery in this human industry we're
making sure that that industry gets
clamped down on uh and making sure this
problem gets brought under control
i mean the critics of this policy will
say that it's unworkable as we're
talking uh minister we're seeing
pictures of people who've crossed the
channel this very morning hundreds in
the past few days i mean do we really
believe that planning to send them to
rwanda would stop these small boats
trying to get across wouldn't they just
take the chance and see that uh british
bureaucracy probably wouldn't work
well we've backdated the policy to
january so anybody's arrived illegally
since january
with the exception of unaccompanied
children face uh being moved to rwanda
and i think that will be a significant
deterrent particularly on those people
smugglers who are profiting from these
huge numbers of people making the
illegal crossing from france to the uk
what about the cost to the british
taxpayer putting on charter flights to
send people to rwanda well it's already
costing a lot of money
the status quo
so we need to make sure that
we have a cost-effective and
humanitarian solution to this but most
of all i want to bear down on the costs
of those who are paying the people
smugglers that those the people i want
to make really unhappy with this policy
are those people profiting
from human beings trying to move in this
way and that is i think uh the cost that
i would like to see come down is those
people smugglers being put out of
business i mean what does this tell us
about the breakdown and relationship
between our government and the french
government millions of pounds were sent
to france to try and stop these people's
mothers putting people onto boats and
now we're planning to send the people
that still make it into the water to
rwanda not doing very well in dealing
with the french are we well a very good
constructive relationship with france as
our nearest neighbor
and that will continue but this is a
separate agreement uh with rwanda uh
trying to find a solution twenty eight
thousand twenty eight thousand five
hundred people crossed the channel
illegally into the uk last year as i
said that compares to just 300 only five
years ago so that is a hundred fold
increase in the number of people moving
the government is taking tough action
here and sending a very clear message
that it won't be possible um to uh uh um
go through those people smugglers um and
uh
and and we will make sure that the uh
the border is defended we put also the
armed forces in charge of
the ministry of defence in charge of the
whole operation uh as well
so those 54 million and plus that was
going to the french government to deal
with migration will still be being sent
do you think as this policy goes forward
well look we'll have to see what happens
in the future but there is no breakdown
in our relationship with france this is
about our relationship with rwanda it's
part of a wider uh deal with rwanda
making sure that those numbers of people
stop coming to the uk
and if they do come to the uk uh they'll
go to rwanda
so you talk about border being defended
you're quite happy with the royal navy
being the ones that are going to be
turning these uh small boats back yes
well we've come to an
agreement that the mod will take charge
of the channel operation
and that is uh that is entirely as you'd
expect the government to be doing to
take making sure that the tough measures
get put in place
that we
clamp down on those people smugglers and
this appalling industry 28 500 people
moved to the uk last year illegally
across the channel
now talking of of tough measures you
know that it's a a rule that if a person
misleads parliament they should resign
the prime minister has found to have
misled parliament should he resign
look the the prime minister will be
speaking to parliament in parliament
this week parliament returns
tomorrow
and the prime minister will have his say
in parliament uh and uh will uh outline
uh his version of events and uh
and face questions from mps and his
version of events mr hands it's not
exactly a full-throated
backing of the prime minister there in
your words what if we see in the coming
days pictures of him pouring drinks
perhaps at a party would that be enough
him to resign
well look i do strongly back the prime
minister i think the prime minister is
getting on with the job he's delivered
and the government has delivered and
anything for the vaccination program
through the strong support
for ukraine and there is a police
investigation um going on and we'll have
to see what develops but as i say the
prime minister uh will be in parliament
this week uh explaining and facing
questions from mps uh about what has
happened
i mean you sound still a little bit
open-minded about what may come with
this mr hand so i've put to the
question about perhaps pictures
emerging what would it take for you to
see we know that the prime minister had
a fine what if he gets another fine for
having broken lockdown rules would that
be enough for you to call him to resign
well look i'm not privy to the police
investigation and i think we'll have to
see
what the police investigation um throws
up but i strongly support you reserving
judgment then still i think one you're
still reserving judgment then as to
exactly what you think should happen to
the prime minister in the coming days if
more revelations come out about him
having broken lockdown rules well i
don't want to pre-judge um the ongoing
police investigation
um what i have been clear on is the
prime minister will answer questions
from mps in the house of commons this
week
and we'll explain um his his version of
events and that i think is entirely
proper but there is an investigation
going on by the police and we'll have to
see
it run its course i mean the problem is
though mr hans his version of events
hasn't always been truthful has it he
said he was ambushed by cake we know
that he turned up to that party for
maybe 10 minutes not ambushed at all
there's now rumors that he was pouring
drinks and leading toast it wasn't a
party until he got there his version of
events doesn't always stand up to
scrutiny does he well i disagree but as
i say he'll be explaining in front of
mps this week
and i wouldn't want to pre-judge an
ongoing police investigation